hey youtubers is Charlie so the flash
versus iris West everyone's like what
that doesn't make any sense but he has
fought her twice in the last couple of
years both on the TV show and in the
comics so this is gonna be an
explanation it's just so much fun there
is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway going on now it's the holiday
season new giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything during
the break so a lot of you are like wait
a minute you know why would the flash
ever fight iris West
they're not together in the comics right
now and on the TV show they've just been
like slowly pushing them together for
the last couple of seasons but in season
one big twist Hannibal Bates emulated
her appearance and they had a knock-down
drag-out Klingon style fight so this is
really the only way I think this would
ever happen on the TV show where the
flash himself would throw a punch at
iris West wait it's me please don't hurt
me
not so hero like treat all your women
like that so of course it was one of my
favorite iris West moments from season
one because you would never think that
the love interest like the person they
would cast to be the love interest on a
TV show like this especially Candice
Patton would actually get in a fistfight
with the person that she's arguably
going to be getting married to someday
we don't know if they'll ever actually
get married on the TV show they might do
it's Smallville style where they get
married at like the very final season in
the very final episode or they
flash-forward to like the distant future
we are supposed to see the future
version of the flash who gets into this
big war with Savitt our and Barry's been
talking about a new suit judicially you
trapped me in eternity your future self
you did this meet Barry and all the
agent my revenge Rises so they're really
only a couple rare circumstances when
the flash actually fights iris West
one of them has to be mind controlled or
has to be a shapeshifter pretending to
be one of the other people so recently
in the comics they had a speed of
darkness arc flash versus iris West
teaser where you're like oh my god are
they actually going to make them fight
so if you haven't been reading the new
flash rebirth comics they basically
reset a lot of the universe and brought
back the ginger Wally West but we also
have the child Kid Flash Wallace West
who's the african-american they
introduced during the new 52 they are -
Wally West's but they age down Wally
West and he's been living with iris West
who is his aunt like his caretaker so to
speak she's not dating Barry Allen he
even had a different love interest in
the first big rebirth arc but that
person went away so over the course of
these first couple new rebirth comic
arts they're like clearing a path for
Barry and iris to start going out and
dating again but in this speed of
darkness arc Wally gets trapped inside
the land of the night shades where the
shade draws his shadows from in Barry
has to go rescue him but iris very
headstrong just charges in and she gets
trapped by the shades - while she's in
there the shades take her and turn her
like poison her against the flash so
within
rapid succession you have two times that
the flash has fought iris west it's
almost like Superman fighting Lois Lane
like there'd have to be some huge twist
you'd either have to take his powers
away you'd have to give her power
somehow the twist here is that iris has
been possessed by the shades she gains
their power the powers of darkness
so it's this opportunity for Wally West
to manifest a new flash power that we
haven't seen before so it's one of those
perfect comic-book setups that makes you
feel compelled to buy the next issue
that's the mark of a good comic when you
just feel like you absolutely have to
buy the next issue so that you find out
what happens so if you don't know who
the shade is they actually just used him
on the flash season three in a slightly
different way
flash just so I came to see say like
shadows I want to try and catch mine
like the light do you know where to hide
now in the comics he's a bit more of
like an English gentleman turned to
crime but in this storyline you see him
after he's tried to become good he met a
woman fell in love tried to leave his
life of crime behind but Godfather style
his shadows rebelled against him and
turned him back to a life of crime in so
he's forced to work with the flash to
try and save his girlfriend and help
save iris West who's also been taken by
the shadows but I like the way he
explains the Shadowlands the place where
darkness went after God created light so
that makes you think a little bit about
Green Lantern's because anytime you talk
about light in the universe you're
talking about the emotional spectrum
you're talking about Green Lantern's but
this is mostly just a flash story so one
of the really cool things is that this
is like a pretty fantastic story that
involves a lot of crazy sets different
costumes so you're like would they ever
do this on the flash take into the
Shadowlands or take him to the MIR world
or even to gorilla City so there is
going to be a gorilla grodd episode in
the back half of the season
it'll be an earth 19 story it'll involve
the accelerated man
Harrison wells teased that they have a
gorilla city on earth 19 so we'll just
follow up with that like we'll be seeing
more from this HR earth 19 Harrison
wells world but you probably noticed
that with each new season the flash has
used more and more special effects to do
like the crazier big stories most of the
time they use it to show off new cool
flash powers or battles with full CG
characters like Grodd or sabotage
avatars like a Grodd style character in
that he is full CG so just like in this
story they might show off the Sunburst
ability like Superman has that Wally
West demonstrates so he basically like
vibrates so much that he gives off a
burst of light and it destroys the
shadows that's how he's finally able to
defeat them they might do that on the TV
show like the lightning throw was the
big season 2 things they showed off it
was this big special effect it looked
really cool but each new season they try
to show off new powers the big thing
that Barry Allen is working on is
learning to enter the Speed Force at
will which is like a giant level above
where he's
right now that's basically what's avatar
is doing when he's appearing here he's
jumping straight out of the speedforce
but because the way he's trapped in the
speedforce existing in this sort of
in-between state he can't make it stick
so let me know in the comments which
comic book abilities do you think that
they're going to give Barry Allen this
season do you think you know like this
flash versus iris West arc they're going
to give him the sunburst in - do you
think that we'll also see him learn to
enter the Speed Force without having to
be vaporized like he was in season two
that was such a cool scene I'm gonna
release the chemicals into his system
the night Barry was struck by lightning
he was doing fingerprint analysis those
chemicals got in his system then and
they are going in now
so you're injecting them into it have to
recreate everything that happened to
Barry that night okay iris love our baby
now
expecto patronum
Great Scott it's working
initiating collision
[Music]
so what's going to happen is is during
the break I'll be doing more of these
epic battles not just flash characters
but other comic-book characters if you
want to recommend a versus video like
Superman versus Lois Lane stuff like
that just write them below in the
comments I think the next one will
probably be the flash versus Supergirl
just because they've had a couple
episodes with them together they've
actually teased that they go up against
each other you always wonder who's the
fastest racer technically it's the flash
but Supergirl is much stronger so that
actually be a pretty awesome fight
hey Supergirl let's finally see who's
faster
so I'll say congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner David you win the
flash ring I already started a new round
I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post a DC video so get hype happy
holidays everybody hopefully you've
started your break I have some Marvel
I'll be posting later tonight then
there'll be more Star Wars game of
Thrones Walking Dead early next week
why you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for all my Star Wars
rogue one Easter eggs and you can click
here to learn about the fastest
speedsters on the flash thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you